transformer un problème récurrent en une
opportunité collective voilà l'idée de
karim directeur général de finis tes
reste 29 une entreprise fondée il y a
deux mois le constat un gâchis
alimentaire difficile à supporter la
promesse un panier garni de plus de 5 kg
contenant au moins cinq légumes
différents le tout pour 5 euros ici tu à
l'atelier de conditionnement donc comme
tu vas pouvoir le voir
mais le navet oignon récupère basse elle
n'avait qu'à pas commercialisé parce
qu'il est trop gros la carotte c'est
parce qu'elle est tordu ou parce qu'elle
est trop grosse le chou-fleur c'est
parce qu'il est trop petit trop petit
trop gros biscornu ces légumes sont
rejetés des étalages de nos supermarchés
et lorsqu'ils ne sont pas récupérés par
fini terrestre il termine soit dans des
places industrielle soit dans la gamelle
des animaux le concept se veut utile et
solidaire c'est pourquoi karim
embauchent des personnes dans le besoin
étudiants retraités par exemple et
s'attache à créer du lien social lire
jeune dame qui m'a écrit un mail à la 70
ans elle a un garage et elle voudrait
accueillir nos paniers pour les
distribuer dans son village pour faire
une bonne heure et puis surtout pour
rencontrer des gens en discuter échanger
et demain pourquoi pas faire de ces
lieux un lieu de bourse aux livres a
lieu de bourses aux fringues pour se
développer karim a décidé d'inclure des
commerces en difficulté en tant que
point de retrait lorsque l'idée est
venue aux oreilles de thierry il a
immédiatement contacté l'entreprise
l'occasion s'est présentée donc voilà
j'ai le sort même genre il ya un message
à karim m'a répondu et c'est parti trois
jours après on annoncé va faire trois
jours après voilà et c'est une super
idée quoi trouve ça super génial il y en
a plus de personnes qui arrivent enfin
ça m'apporte énormément de personnes -
thierry diversifie son activité récupère
une commission et voit sa clientèle
croître d'après karim les commerçants
participants ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires augmenter de 20 à 50 % grâce
à ce partenariat
chaque année c'est un total de 18 % de
la production alimentaire mondiale qui
ne terminerait pas dans les assiettes
des consommateurs